erri Patera not a very experienced net Miner
and he's getting tested right there and that
rebound hopped over a stick of KRA fancy move
across the front of the net Patera was pretty
deep there but he has showed a quick GL hand Bas
chips it out here's Ben Hutton a dep defenseman
getting a chance to play here for VAs takes the
puck walks out got a shot away rebound and B
slinsky called upon to make two stops trying
to work it around the boards kind of fann on
that attempt and Vegas doeses get it out Nick
W at Center being helped out by H they get it
up to cter cter steps in Waits shoots save
rebound bsky down comes back to the point
Martinez with a drive that's blocked here's
C spins away from that check as he saw radish
coming radish has words with him as well no doubt
everybody's still upset about that hitch earlier
on Glen Denny absolutely here's MCD with a shot
right back and they score tapped in by Jonathan
maraso and it's one nothing Vegas yeah it's going
to be that kind of game now because of the Glen
Denning injury for sure marcho just has that
Knack as a goal scorers do left side of your
screen he'll just back away and the lightning
don't pick up everybody radish may have been a
little distracted from being in that altercation
if you want to call with that with cter but they
don't sort it out good play by chernak to come
back though eel was flying The Zone he would
have had a breakway but chernak wasn't looking at
the puck he was looking at the fastest man coming
out of the zone and that's who's going to get
it here's a chance across barbashev scores Mark
stone with a setup and Ivan barbashev with the
finish and it's two nothing Vegas here's kind
of a regroup there's there's eel and two men
on one means that there's a two1 one coming
with stone and barbashev you got to play the
middle of the ice there was no need to come in
and be along the wall there by Nick Paul Nick
Paul should have been in the middle of the ice
more that allowed time and room once they kick
the puck out to him to Stone they get it back to
the line here chernak near side point headman
headman wind fires and that one is banked off
the end boards chernak again to Bar ble out of
the corner comes Conor Sherry hman with a BL TI
scores Alex bar Boule gets the lightning on
the board using all the aspects of it get a
shot you can't get it through fine you get
defenseman pinching down and around you get
Bari Boule making himself available Cherry
gets it back iceon gets it back to the point
and in Victor Hedman with a rolling Puck
the key here is see how he stays down on
it it's a Rolling Puck from that distance
if you tilt your shoulders up and try to
hit it just as hard as you can chances are it's
going to sail Victor hman COV things tighten up
here's headman Waits shoots and Patra got
that with a stick and his stick came flat
out of his hands White Club gave it back to him
he's still scrambling they score m ceral ties the
game they were not going to be denied some
excellent Puck movement here some fakes the
three guys that are out there watch this one
when the stick flies so that's a little bit
of a preoccupation there trying to get the
stick back he gets it handed back to him
but can't get the handle on it so he lets it
down on the ice again now he's off balance a
move with the flow the way they normally
do he can't get across and with his stick
or not with his stick I don't think he
would have got there anyway Point works
it around the boards here's Stan GH works
it back across to CRA krov carries that
down low hangs on with looking for
option AC cross goes off a SK then
score scrambling front tipped in and the lightning
had the lead on a power play goal by Braden Point
another situation where they're just not
going to be denied the calmness of coocher
off as usual gring points in the middle coocha
is measuring he fits it through trying to get
it to stammer but it actually went off the foot
of he and stays right there in the scoring area
everybody's looking for it Bren points in
the best position to find it because he's
facing the net Nick Paul is not ha is not and
Braden point just Wills this one into the back
of the net Stevenson tried to split the KN
following up that hops away from Maro and
it's turned back for COV COV he's in shoot
stopped by Patra good movement to his game
always a Keak into the middle for points points
who is given the lightning the lead here tonight
K drop out in front oh hits the post that was
Nick po rebound scores brighten points again
and the lightning burn Vegas kucherov with some
hard work and always with a plan before he gets
to the puck a beautiful backhand pass the first
one there it is there's the first chance and
a deflection that was Square Off The Joint
of the crossbar and the pipe look where the
goenda no idea what was going on he's spinning
around in the wrong direction the intensity of
Braden point he ran out of things to do there
because of the back check of H but it was the
yelling at the referee that got him in trouble
so a good D in the Box third power play of the
night for Vegas trying to cut their deficit to
one down low on in front they score and that
did not take long maraso with a power play
goal his second of the game and and it is 43
you're not going to win the conversation
but it lets him say what he wants to say
that's good refereeing from that standpoint
but look at the execution on this power play
goal down below to the side of the net right
out in front we see the lightning D this all
the time March or so is wide open there going to
turn away from radish radish hangs with him it's
bit back to the point across to mcad McNab back
up top Hutton back to mcad here CAU with a shot
scores an extended shift inside their own blue
line and Vegas cashes Paul conter and this one
I don't think Bassy just got a good look at
it extended play Lightning are good in good
shape yeah I think it was the traffic in front
radish has got his man in front probably a moving
screen yeah there we go yeah radish ends up taking
bass's eyes away it was the pivoting around by
Nicholas uh Roy and he's being watched by radish
so they're kind of swinging around in circles and
then it's just the shot and here's what here's how
vassi felt about it after the F got her away to
perix perix up ahead to CRA pass got away from him
knocked back by Vegas comes back out to center ice
now it's Braden Point again point with two goals
on the night Point takes the shot kicks a rebound
SC from the corner Nick Paul
54 the initial Rush is terrific the Finish is
even better watch Victor Hedman go to the net
he gets a piece of this one I think but the
golender is so committed to Victor Hedman and
I think it freezes him for for a second watch the
goenda come in they go down the walls in case the
puck comes off the end wall or they want to use
the around the boards in order to keep the puck
in the zone 3.1 on the clock Paul again against
W pull back there's patrula his shot block Hegel
chops at it and that's it and a spectacular
night of hockey finishes with a Lightning win